[Music]
ten years ago I worked with my friend
Luke on the hot dusty plains of West
Texas I recently reconnected with Luke
and when I did he shared with me an
unsettling story when Luke was in
college and recently married he came
across an abandoned hunting rifle which
he dutifully took down to the local
police station to turn it while he was
there he was told that the rifle had
been reported missing and that he was
under arrest for possession of a stolen
firearm a serious felony Luke spent the
next six days in jail on charges that
were ultimately dropped and for the
first three days his wife had no idea
where he was because she had an
out-of-state cellphone number and a jail
wouldn't allow long-distance calls
so what was of the kept Luke in jail not
just overnight but for six days it was
bail set at $100,000 now if your college
jobs were at all like mine which at one
point included Campus Bookstore return
specialist $100,000 was just way beyond
out of reach and it was relieved too but
bail is rigid it isn't means-tested it's
an old system that needs reform to
better align with our values we live in
a society that values the promise of
liberty and justice for all
but our pretrial justice system is only
delivering liberty and justice for some
so today can we do three things together
first let's take a walk into this
pretrial justice system something that
you may never may have never thought
about and until recently I hadn't either
second let's consider if it matters
whether someone spends the time between
their arrest and their trial in jail
and third let's look at way as the Uni
will interact with the system going
forward before we get going I just feel
an obligation to acknowledge that I am
not the typical person to address a
topic like this I've had a lucky
upbringing nobody in my family has spent
time in jail but it makes me angry to
think about Luke and his wife separated
for six days and it isn't just Luke
every night in the u.s. seven hundred
thousand people sit in local jails sixty
percent of them are there just waiting
for their trial so to walk into this
system after arrest everyone will face
one of three doors so door number one
release this is where people who are low
risk not too much of a danger to the
community and are likely to show up to
all of their court dates they're free to
go until the time of their trial door
number two detention this is where
people who are high risk they may not be
likely to show up to all of their court
dates or they may have been charged with
a particularly egregious offence and so
they'll stay in jail until the time of
their child door number three bail this
is the door that most people have to
walk through bail requires that someone
deposit money with the court that they
will only get back even when they show
up for all of their court dates and if
you think about it that's kind of a good
system in principle I mean we want some
sort of incentive for people to show up
for court but when you dig into the data
it's clear that this is a tricky door to
have to walk through you see in San Jose
two years ago the average bail amount
was twenty seven thousand dollars twenty
seven thousand dollars is enough to buy
a brand-new Toyota Camry with leather
seats or make a down payment on a house
anywhere outside of the Bay Area
so this is like a lot of money and to me
this is compelling evidence that our
pretrial justice system keeps people in
jail simply based on who can and who
cannot pay so on the one hand you people
with means who can pay their way out of
jail regardless of their risk to society
and on the other hand your people like
Luke
people who are stuck behind bars simply
because they can't pay now to topic
number two doesn't matter if someone
spends this time between arrest and
trial in jail or not if someone is
unable to pay bail they can wait for
weeks or months for that trial and over
the course of that time at risk of
losing a job a relationship with a
significant other and if and when they
do get out it is that much harder to put
food on the table or pay rent now it
isn't just the sort of run-of-the-mill
everyday life stuff that gets it changes
Brooklyn defender services look at two
groups of people that they serve in New
York City group number one these are
folks who stayed in jail between the
time of their arrest and trial and group
number two these are people who got out
you know what they found
group number one was five times more
likely to end up with a criminal
conviction five times and you know what
contributes to this it's the fact that
when you're in jail it's hard to meet
with your lawyer it's hard to build your
case and some people will plead guilty
simply to move the process along but
that criminal conviction follows them
when they apply for jobs in the future
or try to rent an apartment and so the
bottom line here is that getting out
really matters to illustrate this I'd
like to share the story of kalief
Browder and some of you may be familiar
with his tragic tale Khalif was a 16
year old living in New York City when he
was arrested for allegedly stealing a
backpack his bail was set at only three
thousand dollars but his family couldn't
afford that
Khalif spent the next three years on
Rikers Island a notorious jail facility
in New York at the end of those three
years his charges were dropped
and he wasn't convicted of anything and
sadly just a couple years after his
release
Calise committed suicide and many point
to the mental and emotional trauma of
his time in jail as a major contributing
factor so how does this happen I mean
this is insane
three thousand dollars cost him three
years and his life Khalif didn't have
his Liberty and as a result he lost his
shot at justice so again the bottom line
here is the getting out really matters
how are you and I going to interact with
the system going forward now we may
never have to walk through any one of
these three doors but you're going to
read articles about this topic online
and you'll be asked to vote on criminal
justice reform issues in your home state
I am NOT the only person talking about
this John Oliver did a spot on bail the
New York Times and NPR are writing about
it and jay-z actually just produced a
mini-series on the kalief Browder story
so read these articles and get informed
because you will be asked to weigh in
I'd like to share two examples of this
in 2014 New Jersey passed a ballot
measure that did away with their old
money bail system and it replaced it
with a RISC algorithm now what this does
is it scores every defendant on a scale
from one to six and it's based on their
likelihood of not showing up to court
and their risk to the community so this
score based on their actual risk is what
determines whether they stay in jail or
not it's not their ability to pay and
while these algorithms are not perfect
by any means they're an important step
forward in the right direction
a little bit closer to home there's
actually a bill working its way through
the California Legislature currently it
would have similar effects so the
this is relevant for us right now it
would shift people from door number
three Bale to door number one release
now for the last year I've been working
with a team of students here at Stanford
to find business based solutions to this
problem and if this is at all
interesting to you I have all ears
please come talk to me
smart interested folks like yourselves
are critical for coming up with a better
system
so I want you to leave here today
knowing that this matters this matters
to the Luc's it matters to the khalif's
and it matters to thousands of others
who are trapped in our pretrial justice
system so let's renew a commitment to
our values and let's take an important
step forward in delivering on the
promise of liberty and justice not just
for some but liberty and justice for all
[Applause]
[Music]